there's Monday to baby sit down this
Likud campaign spot is called babysitter
these parents are waiting for their
babysitter instead they opened the door
to Benjamin Netanyahu the israeli
premier also known as BB promises their
child will be safe if he wins reelection
keep alton babysitter wanna do security
has been one of the dominant themes of
the campaign so far netanyahu is hoping
the issue will help him win a fourth
term in office he's counting on the
votes of people in towns like kiryat got
close to the gaza strip his supporters
here are campaigning hard that's your
baby we've hardly had any terrorist
attacks since BB came to power oh no
Miasha booked on arville in he also
built the security fence in the south
he's a straight talker what matters to
me in my country is that he's offering
us security Shelly maybe the hon here's
Netanyahu enjoying a photo op at a
market in Jerusalem it's rare for the
premier to appear in a crowd but he
knows he's fighting for every vote the
latest polls show a tight race against
his main challenger the Zionist Union
coalition for Netanyahu it could be an
uphill struggle at the end of the day it
turned out to be an election about one
person Prime Minister Binyamin Netanyahu
he was the one who decided about these
elections he took a big chance he had
two more secure years in office and he
thought I'll go and I'll take it very
easily until recently Netanyahu's
re-election had seemed like a done deal
and security is not the only issue
Israelis care about the cost of living
continues to rise rents have increased
so has the cost of health care at Tel
Aviv's caramel market voters have me
opinions on six years of Netanyahu hey
budget mode and Israelis have enough of
him as Prime Minister it's time for him
to go all these scandals and we're
always talking about Iran the people
have had it up to here I know Sara
Errani namaz gamma energy like a baby
police land bebe is the one for Israel
he knows how to represent us in the
world he's won the last few Wars he's
got my vote hlo aquatica vote Netanyahu
will soon know whether he made the right
bet in calling early elections